new research sheds light on how the
coronavirus may affect pregnant women to
new york city hospitals tested more than
200 women admitted for delivery whether
they showed symptoms or not the results
published just this week in the New
England Journal of Medicine revealed
nearly 90% of the women who tested
positive showed no symptoms at all our
Nikki batise is 37 weeks pregnant almost
there Nikki what did your doctor tell
you gal good morning I've been told I'll
have to wear a mask and I will be tested
as soon as I arrive at the hospital in
labor if I test positive I'll be
isolated as staff take special
precautions for one New York family
expecting a child
there'ii our trip was nearly too late we
talked to a man whose wife gave birth
even after coronavirus comprar
complications left her comatose Namira
Soriano met her newborn son for the
first time Wednesday after spending
nearly two weeks in a medically induced
coma it
yanira husband Walter Sanchez told us
she was eight months pregnant when she
went to the emergency room with a severe
fever struggling to breathe after
testing positive for kovat 19 she was
quickly intubated at that point Walter
said the doctors conducted an emergency
c-section while yanira was on a
ventilator hospitals across New York are
preparing for similar situations we
really advocate for dr. dena Goffman is
with the Columbia University Irving
Medical Center she co-authored a new
study of more than 200 pregnant women at
two New York City hospitals 33 women
tested positive for coronavirus but 29
of them showed no symptoms if we're not
checking we really do risk missing
people who are carrying the virus I'm 37
weeks pregnant if I come in and test
positive would you recommend separating
my newborn from me for a mom who's
asymptomatic and feeling well we think
there are ways to potentially keep them
together to allow for some of the fun
so far studies have not shown
coronavirus passes to the baby from the
womb or through breast milk but dr.
Kaufman says asymptomatic mothers should
wear masks while around their newborns
and for people with life-threatening
symptoms like Kim Mira Soriano it's not
just childbirth believing the hospital
as a healthy mom that is a life-changing
miracle partners and spouses at the New
York hospitals who are testing pregnant
women for Cova 19 have their
temperatures taken upon arrival that
would be my husband if he has a fever he
will not be allowed inside Gail well I
was running about that Nicki cuz last
time you were on the set you weren't
sure if your husband couldn't be in the
delivery room sounds like he can how
long can he stay he can only stay for
the delivery in an hour or two after
then when I moved to postpartum he has
to leave all right I'm just glad he'll
be there at that moment Thank You Nicki
batise that is a bit of good news